on le sait disney est une marque qui
fait attention à son image si son coeur
de cible et la famille que ce soit par
ses jouets ces films où ces parcs
son but est de fabriquer de la magie et
de ne surtout choqué personne c'est avec
sa plateforme de streaming disney plus
que la compagnie a décidé de pratiquer
un peu de sang sur disney en effet
décidé de placer certaines oeuvres sous
contrôle parental ainsi les enfants
devront demander l'autorisation de leurs
parents avant de les regarder en cause
d'éléments pouvant être vécu comme
raciste par certaines communautés
ainsi dans le livre de la jungle le roi
des singes sifflotant du jazz peut être
vu comme un élément raciste du film tout
comme les yeux [ __ ] des chats siamois
dans les aristochats et la belle et le
clochard dans peter pan les peaux rouges
sont la caricature d'amérindiens autant
d'éléments qui ont poussé disney à se
censurer
alors comprenez vous que certains films
disney fasse polémique et ça c'est
incroyable pour moi alors je vous dis
voilà par exemple alors je vais prendre
on n'a pas le choix de mettre les images
mais dans la belle et le clochard
beaucoup de monde a critiqué les chats
siamois et ses yeux [ __ ] notamment de
risa c'est à la crap
c'est possible parce qu'ils sont
méchants sont énormes et dans peter pan
landaul dessins animés peter pan c'est
la représentation des indiens qui pose
problème est venu avant la couleur de
peau ou choix dans le livre de la jungle
c'est une assimilation des singes et de
leurs droits louis à la population
afro-américaine qui a été retenu à
charge sans oublier l'ère jay-z jazzy
sur lequel l'orang outan chanson
aspirations d easy web c'est parce que
j'ai l'habitude de l'appeler comme son
inspiration à devenir un homme
ce qui avait aussi beaucoup fait réagir
deux beaux dans le dessin animé de mme
bossé la scène des corbeaux qui a été
qualifié de raciste à plusieurs reprises
et la petite sirène c'est le crabe
sébastien fait polémique à cause de sa
voix de chanteur de reggae les
aristochats c'est la présence d'un chat
donc où lady et fantasia dans ce court
métrage fantasia on pouvait voir des
ceintures nos descentes or noir polir
les sabots du chanteur blond voilà
aideront mais est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec tout ça est ce qu'il faut
vraiment enlever tous à isabelle non un
an mais moi je trouve ça et que la
démarche viennent de la compagnie
elle-même
je trouve ça absolument indigne et ça
n'a rien à voir avec le respect dû aux
mains de groupes ce soit c'est juste de
la lâcheté de la couille
donc moi je trouve ça mais ali sable ces
films sont au contraire on en lait ont
loué à l'époque cette espèce d'ouverture
le jazz tout ça dans le
la jungle et vingt ans après dire que
c'est qu'un problème de racisme c'est
impensable
alors que mais moi ce que je comprends
pas c'est on s'est plié à qui à quoi à
quel smad h qui a décidé sa maîtresse a
rien à ce qu'ils ont fait du zèle battre
non mais c'est ça qui est dingue parce
que là nous on est tous autour de la
table je vous crois pas que c'est
quelqu'un qui a acquis sa pose problème
c'est quand même enfin moi je ça me tue
c'est aujourd'hui vous avez un droit
fois cette saison
ce qui n'empêche écrit je trouve que les
gens qui remarque ça pour moi c'est eux
qui sont ces ça c'est exact c'est ça qui
vous ferez bon temps mais ça moi je suis
pareil gérer à ce moment là tu peux plus
rien faire c'est des trucs qu'ils ont
fait avancer des chefs-d'oeuvre sont là
tu peux plus regarder de films de louis
de funès parce qu'il ya aussi des trucs
là dedans belmondo tu peux tu regardes
un maroc plus faire muriel robin et qui
a fait fait que ça tu ne peux plus rien
faire alors il ya eu 4 me contre le vent
quand même oui aujourd'hui d'accord on a
évolué ça y est on est on est plus
intelligent qu'avant va dire on va dire
ça comme ça mais que la santé tout le
monde moi je me suis dit ce n'est sur
des dix net objet de dire c'est
n'importe quoi les mecs détendez vous et
moi je suis comme toi le premier qui se
plaint de faire ça s'échange aux
artistes en vérité car aussi on remarque
ça nous géraldine sauf qu on s'offusque
que tous autour de la table et on est
tous d'accord mais sauf que aux états
unis il faut voir que c'est une lame de
fond idéologique dans les universités
ils sont tous gong rennais lorsqu'on
appelle là quand cette culture en fait
ils veulent pas à avertir
ils veulent pas apprendre ils veulent
effacer ils veulent reese était notre
culture alors aujourd'hui par exemple la
petite sirène c'est sexiste en a dégagé
cendrillon qui attend un homme riche
pour la sauver effacer ça c'est là qu'en
de cette culture quand elle côtoie mais
vous ne pouvez pas vous imaginer le mal
que ça fait très dire qu'aujourd'hui
en fait on censure de manière agressive
au nom du droit à ne pas être offensés
donc tout le monde peut être au fond
c'est potentiellement et je vous assure
que c'est en train d'arriver en france
petit à petit le camélia jordana nous on
va parler peut-être tout à l'heure il
est parrainé les trains cette culture à
saint gall en juin à bagua ménages en
valeur va en parler dans un instant
juste toi venir avec vous l'annoncé on
est beaucoup trop dans l'excès on met du
racisme partout là où il y en a pas et
alors franchement ça y est ils ont
évolué en plus disney il faut resituer
avec l'époque hockey ce serait peut-être
plus en face je le reconnais aujourd'hui
avec la société actuelle
mais depuis les années 90 on voit des
princesses arabes noirs chinoise donc là
on n'en de dire qu'il ya du racisme et
en plus chez disney pas d'accord ratera
tort braschaat or il comprend pas du
basket je n'ai pas grand chose à dire là
effectivement dans ce cas là on va plus
monter des images de l'ina on va tous
remontés bah oui parce qu'il y aura des
choses qu'on pourra plus passer à la
télévision
qu'est ce qui va se passer après c'est
quoi la suite ses disques haddad mais
c'est exactement
est ce que ce serait pas un truc
hypocrite de leur part pour qu'on
continue à regarder leurs dessins animés
pour faire perdurer la marque vous
voulez que je vous dise c'est peut-être
mais je pense qu'ils se sont faits très
bonne pub
voilà voilà ici parce qu'ils sont dits
tout le monde va parler 15 10 ans je
suis un peu son retour d'exil c'est pas
une bonne pub sur une régression totale
on voit qu'ils ont ou alors ils
subissent mais palacio ces pressions
américaines dont parle et culturel et
que vous le disiez ça me fait plaisir
c'est tout c'était la fin de votre à ça
c'était très intéressant
les boues fait attention à ce genre de
détails pour des dessins animés qui sont
produits aujourd'hui à la rigueur je
veux bien même s'il allait réellement
franchement c'est ma parlant du tout
mais qu'on supprime et qu'on censure des
classiques comme ça on l'a tous vu ça se
transmet de génération en génération et
ricky des minorités puissent pas voir ça
sur la nature aujourd'hui c'est
dramatique lui avait raison cyril c'est
quand on parle du site parce qu'en fait
ce sont des messages de sensibilisation
qui a maintenant juste avant le film et
les enfants donc eu accès au dessin
animé dans la catégorie adulte à moi y
avait un avertissement c'est interdit
mais castaldi alors moi je trouve que
disney ferait mieux de d'être très
vigilants sur son mode de recrutement du
personnel plutôt que de servir de coup
de pub ou pour un fait qui n'existe pas
il ya pas de racistes d'eni dans ses
dessins animés la voilà voilà ce que je
pense à présent vous êtes encore au
tennis on va voir ce qu'on pense et à ce
que ça je suis très alors oui ah non à
90%
merci merci